hi I'm GL and today I will present our
works one a software driven wide area
network resource controller network
operators today use mpls te to allocate
by area network resources among data
centers which can lead to two problems
the first problem is low utilization
because today's wide area network are
over provisioned in order to ensure
sufficient capacity for pig periods we
are able to improve utilizations through
traffic shaping by delaying elastic
traffic that does not have a tight
deadline to meet second it's hard to
guarantee SOAs in today's mpls te where
each router independently use a greedy
path selection algorithm as a result we
found many LSPs are suffering from
inflated latency we solve this by using
a centralized T to prove wrong global
route and rate control now show you how
swine looks like consider wide area
network that bridges for data centers in
our test that we have three servers in
each data center and those servers are
connecting to when through a border
router which we use this cleanse lucado
juniper each data center also has a pub
which consists of two Sdn enable
switches for load balancing and photo
ruins in our task that we use a mix of
IBM blade and a result switches we also
have to transit pub for increase
capacity and then we well connect pops
where each Interpublic actually
represent two parallel physical links
now consider three services across
appears of data centers the top one has
the highest priority while the bottom
one has the list priority the question
here is how to dynamically allocate the
path and bandwidth to ensure both hi
neighbor utilization and high SOA
satisfaction to achieve this we operate
globos when
controller which collect bandwidth
demand from service hosts and collect
topology and traffic information from
the network and then it performs global
traffic engineering and push the result
back to the both sides service hast also
performed rate-limiting to you for rape
enforcement in the right hand side which
are network topology each node is a
switch and color represent utilization
red means high utilization and thus we
show that we are able to achieve high
validation for most of the links except
for a few green links which are
introducing links used only for
redundancy in the left-hand side we show
the time series of three services
running in our testbed they are sending
the OTO traffic pattern blue line
represents service demand and red line
represent the allocated down with the
highest priority service in the top is
always getting oh it needs and the other
services dynamically modulated in this
one controller Council we can sure
there's a three service running in the
system
each line here shows the bandwidth and
the past allocation for inter DC flow
using global rate and route control we
see this high priority service always
taking shortest paths while the low
priority flows can use multiple and
longer palace to achieve high
utilization
now we kill a link between two switches
co one and CH 1 and C house when
controller will deal with a link value
after the link is down in a swank
controller we cease when controller can
quickly react and detect the link
failure and it recompute the path and
then with a location only for the
affected service after the fast recovery
we can see some high-priority flows now
need to take a longer path while there
are still have full bandwidth allocation
thanks for watching the video please
visit our website for more detailed
information